The secret sauce in Tornado for achieving the
scalability is the concept called clustered object. The idea
is that from the point of view of
all the pieces of the operating system, executing on
the different nodes, there's a single object reference.
The object reference is the same. But the object
reference under the covers may have multiple representations.
So for instance, n0 may have a represenatation that
it is lookating at, different from n1, different
from n2 but the object reference is the same.
So there is an illusion of a single object. So, that's what I meant when I said
logically the operating system designer. I think of
a shared data structure's logically the same thing. But
physically, it may be replicated under the covers. Course,
who decides to replicate it, that's the decision of
the operating system as well. We'll see that in a minute. This is where the idea
of clustering comes about. The na, the name
clustered object. The degree of clustering, that is, the
replication of a particular object, it's an implementation choice of
the service, so as a designer of the service you make a decision whether
a particular object is going to have a singleton representation,
or is going to be one per core in the machine or one per cpu meaning
it is shared by all the cores that may be there on a single cpu. Or maybe one
representation of an object for a group of
processes. So these are all design decisions that is
left up to the implementor of the service. But
when designing the service, you can think abstractly about
the components of the service containing objects and
each object is giving you the illusion that it
is single object reference. But under the covers
you might choose to implement the object with different
level up replication, and of course if we
are talking about replicated objects you have to worry
about the consistency of the replicated objects, and
this is were the, suggestion in the tornado system
is to maintain the consistency of the objects.
Through protective procedure call, that is implemented under
the colors in the operating system. So in
other words, as a designer of the service, you
are going to orchestrate the sharing of the
data structures that are replicated and you orchestrate
maintenance of the consistency of the share data
structures. Through protective procedure call that you execute across
these replicas, and don't use the hardware coherence
mechanism in order to maintain the consistency, and
the reason for that is the hardware cache
coherence it can be indiscriminate about how it does
the hardware cache coherence whenever you touch a
shared memory location. If it is present elsewhere, it
is going to update that. And that's the
reason we don't want to incur the overhead of
the hardware cache coherence and replicate it. But if
you replicate it then the hardware is normal. And,
therefore, you have to worry about keeping these copies
consistent with one another. But, of course, when in doubt,
use a single representation. And that way, you have
the hardware cache coherence as a security blanket when you're
not sure yet about the level of clustering that
you want in order to reduce the amount of contention
for shared data structures. All of these may seem
a little bit abstract at this point of time,
but I'll make it very concrete, when we talk
about a simple example, namely the memory management subsystem.